[Música]
eu ainda não sei como é que eu consegui
fazer está muito igualado junto a isso
mas o mundo do samba
pessoal quem fala da crise muito bem
vindos
estudamos o vídeo era lançar uma
pergunta polêmica o qual o melhor jogo
para mobile project mobile ou frei fire
como embaixo eu tô pra ver quantos
comentários é que eu vou ter que neste
vídeo e texto prevê também qual é que
vocês acham que eu uso e também como
fazer que prestígio pessoal do tipo uma
idéia que eu nunca vi um sujeito youtube
ninguém aqui na internet fazer que é
tornar as coisas do free fire na vida
real e agora pessoalmente muito aqui no
espírito que vocês acharam muito vaidoso
vai partilhar mais lá também mas vai lá
o que interessa pessoal vamos mostrar
aqui é que tenho é que eu encontrei ele
na garagem uma catana velho é uma catana
super enferrujada então vou tentar
aproveitar esta campanha para fazer uma
do fifa ele como podem ver o que ela
está toda enferrujada está muito boa
pensão isso não é uma campanha de terror
da al qaeda lâmina não está afiada como
podem ver tá bem suja
sempre que não sabe como é que eu tenho
é que eu estou a falar eu vou deixar
aqui um trecho de um vídeo pra vocês
verem
vou tentar fazer esta catarina vida real
eu vou conseguir vou manter
[Música]
sabem pessoal de segurança acima de tudo
bem louca
[Música]
i
neste momento está muito quente a nossa
catarina mas pelo menos há pouco já está
a sair e depois foi fazer um acabamento
muito melhor mas pelo menos já está
brilhante olha aí nossa eterna
[Música]
só lamento por dia conta do chá daira
aconteceu aqui um acidente ela foi parar
aqui olha está completamente a partida
possa que bosta mas coisa positiva a
nossa lâmina está completamente fechada
né
[Música]
só que só a luta como escrava ela fica
bem lisa mesmo então nós vamos ter que
fazer isso toda o leiam e só depois
concluir que para ela ficar bem
brilhante como estava ok frança em baixa
então vai ser trabalhar então nosso
carro da catana e ainda não sei bem como
é que eu vou fazer isso e seguiu assim
com particular tem que escutar uma volta
e vou tentar esta parte aqui fora eu vou
pintar por dentro e depois vai para
outra vez
[Música]
enquanto isso só vamos então imprimir em
3d é a peça que está numa educado e de
lâmina para nós conseguimos ter um
suporte para o nosso punho qualquer
forma que vocês podem mudar uma catana
inteira mas eu não quero cantar eu só
quero esta parte aqui então eu vou secar
o modelo só desta peça aqui e vou dar um
corta aqui em cima para imprimir sem a
menina então vamos tentar fazer isso fez
dois porque o 5 a participar com a parte
de baixo e fica uma forma muito mais
dura e mais resistente né e você vai
fazer isso para lá
[Música]
ok temos a parte uma parte de baixo pois
é só juntar eu até já estar aqui enfiar
a lâmina
meu deus quase quase entrou não espere
se eu fizer assim o hernanes parece foi
então divida 'olha aí é normal ter
citado assim com esta coisa eu não sei
mas diz ter fugido por mim e em troca de
energia também assim rua e amor é um
ataque frontal já o soldado gustavo
morais precisarem de catarse ou tocar
[Música]
a lei
e eu acho que já temos pintar para o
irmão sol enquanto todos e caiu embaixo
nós vamos tratar então dos pronomes da
capa da coletânea quando há de vir aqui
pela imagem nós temos quatro
acampamentos na capa que são tipo 4
risquinhos bromélias e nós vamos fazer
isso com uma corda mas como não tinha
corda e única coisa que eu tinha aqui em
casa era este o caso do é nós vamos
fazer esse movimento com estão a tentar
fazer aqui umas tranças e vamos tentar
dar um acabamento mais favorável para
ficar mais preciso a espada do free
firehawk
[Música]
é que está a nossa trança pessoal eu
acho que o efeito muito louco olha aí ok
mas qualquer forma nós temos que esperar
e tudo aquilo sec e já porque há imenso
tempo e eu acho que ele vai ter que
provar outra de mão
eu não sei
[Música]
ae
otto tive aqui mesmo tempo a tentar
colar o tecido preto no cabo de madeira
e comemorei muito tempo a fazer isso eu
não gostei porque aí ficar aqui maior
sei lá mas felizmente deu certo tá
prefeito sério tá prefeito vou muito
tempo a colocar o time novo clube com
cola quente aqui dentro então está bem
preso com uma pega bem firme
ok agora só falta estudos carga ainda
demora
[Música]
o bom som onze da noite algumas peças já
ficaram vamos montar podem ver o nosso
já tem aqui que é o complemento mas
ficou muito louco está muito igual
acatando do free fire a ordem próximo
passo vai ser colocada então essa pessoa
aqui do meio apareceu naquela mina que
está pronto eu acho vai ficar qualquer
coisa deste ano
muito bonita e eu digo a china não está
muito parecida à campanha do frio aí tá
muito por cima já olha isso inglês que
tem vacina olha eu incrível eu to facto
defendo estúpido estúpido tudo tudo
a fixa
eu acho que ela fixa é incrível
agora já li shishi 321 vai ou não ficar
a cada caixa portanto ela está vinculada
o livro
olha aí a nossa querida que também está
completamente seca ela por uma cheia
ensino estava velho é daqueles que já
foi usada pelo mundo está morais então
tá
eu gostei o
[Música]
cada vez mais esta carta nesta parte da
campanha do free fire pessoal deixei
muito leve que eles iriam ser sincero eu
penso muito líquido se vocês gostarem
muito que desfilou fazer mais coisas na
vida real do frio a europa está
produzindo e agora é só juntar as peças
essa unir mas ainda falta um pormenor
que eu sei que vocês esqueceram como é
que tá nesse método nas costas para o
ataque fora eu já tinha comprado a 500
detectores pro caso né
mas eu acho que vou precisar de uns fica
a música já assim nem quer saber como
fica jacinta me manin o pessoal está
feito está a tentar aprimorar a nossa
cana parede fica muito louca só por um
emprego ou qualquer coisa assim
olha aí funciona não não é assim será
ver daqui puxa se imaginar eu acho para
aí sim essa opção é também aqui ó
entrou ninguém se mexe comigo foi assim
até o final de 2010 pessoal esta é nossa
que a terna do free fire na vida real em
3 2 1
olha isso
é ser eu ainda não sei como é que eu
consegui fazer está muito igualado junto
por isso o presidente koff fire sexual
muito obrigado por terem insistindo
vídeo até que eu adorei fazer este
projecto já sabem se quiser ver mais
vídeos destes free fire na vida real
aqui no canal comentei muito em baixo
deixei muito claro que mesmo se quiserem
um próximo filho pois o macaé no próximo
vídeo editado esta cana é cortar objetos
comentem muito em baixo muito e nós
chegarmos aos 150 mil akz aqui neste
vídeo vou fazer ver nitidamente exibir o
capitão documento e deixa muito alegre
muito obrigado pessoal fica a idéia é
aproximar o edifício entrada do homem
e agora